foreign
[Music]
company we are primarily focused on Eye
Care
Solutions or platform is used by eye
care doctors
optometrists and ophthalmologists to
practice telemedicine
we embarked on a dual Cloud strategy and
we wanted to make sure that we choose a
cloud where there is plenty of you know
healthcare related services available
the infrastructure is robust and there
is an ecosystem of providers actually
who can
who can help us bring the level of the
care that that our our providers want to
provide to the patients
during migration right I mean being able
to peer or [ __ ] existing mongodb
clusters running on Atlas mongodb Atlas
service pairing them appearing them with
our infrastructure on Google Cloud
Google and and support was actually able
to bring in resources not only the
networking resources from Google Cloud
side but also from mongodb side
who sat down together with our engineers
and solved those problems or actually do
the peering make sure that all the
infrastructure is is tightly secured and
deployed and it works and can be
recovered and things like that so
networking tends to be quite complex and
we have limited experience in networking
and in our team as such but Google Cloud
support was able to arrange all those
resources for us and explain us and make
it work for us actually so that was the
greatest value ad we found initially
when we were migrating to Google Cloud
the infrastructure is robust and the
support that we get from from Google uh
is is pretty incredible and so far in
last three years we have literally
maintained 100 uptime on on Google Cloud
[Music]